this video is sponsored by brilliant the
first 200 to use the link in the
description get 20% off the annual
subscription September 9th 1976 the day
Mao Zedong died three decades after
founding the People's Republic of China
few countries are so easily divided into
two distinct eras with his death the
economic walls around the red dragon
slowly fell allowing the largest
population on earth access to the world
economy in 1978 there were essentially
zero private companies all were
state-owned with only a tiny 140,000
people or 0.01 percent of its population
employed privately just three years
later thanks to Mouse successor dung
Xiao ping that number was already 16
times higher China in the 80s and 90s
was the golden opportunity to start a
company big inefficient state-owned
corporations had left huge gaps in the
economy people were moving to the city
finally with money to spend and the
government was eager to encourage
enterprise which is to say ren jiang fee
couldn't have picked a better time than
1987 to start his company called Huawei
a few years later it won a contract with
the People's Liberation Army which
although small in financial terms was
huge for winning favor with a communist
party who then protected the company
from competition with this help Huawei
became today the second largest phone
company in the world just ahead of Apple
and behind only Samsung up until a few
months ago it was expected to pass
Samsung to become number one lead the
world in the spread of 5g and gain even
more market share than its current 29%
of all telecommunications equipment on
earth then with one swift signature
Huawei was banned not only does this
stop the company from selling equipment
in the US but all hallway products
everywhere are banned from working with
American companies who supply hallway
with components like Intel chips and
software like the Google Play Store so
is hallway as the United States claims a
real threat to national security a
Trojan horse for the Chinese government
or is the band merely a political the
problem with most answers to these
questions is that they focus only on the
technology the politics or China but to
really understand Huawei you have to
marry all three who really owns a
company it's a pretty reasonable
question and should have a pretty simple
answer you don't usually need to go
around reading Articles of Incorporation
just some common sense a few decent
clues are whoever's office is on the
hundredth floor or maybe whoever's
business card is most expensive it even
has a watermark but not always because
of course the structure of a company is
not designed for our legibility but
rather to make more money or limit
somebody's power so you see lots of
weird subsidiaries holding companies
without employees based in the Virgin
Islands deliberately confusing names and
dual class shares things can get weird
take John for example of Papa fame who
facing public pressure resigned as the
company chairman a few weeks later John
decided actually he'd like to return to
his pizza Papa position the board said
yeah hard pass and changed the company's
bylaws to block their own largest
shareholder from taking over the company
he founded he then sued his own company
one time a pharmaceutical company called
Rockwell medical split into two legal
corporations each claiming to be the
real legitimate Rockwell medical
incorporated with the same address and
same shareholders leaving everyone
wondering who's the real Pope
the point is it's actually not that
simple of a question and that's before
you add the whole socialism twist if you
do ask Kwame who owns the company
they'll happily take you to a special
room in their Shenzhen headquarters
where a giant Blue Book because little
in red were taken sits behind glass
exactly the way you'd expect a
multibillion-dollar tech company to keep
its records in it Huawei says is a list
of every person who own shares in the
company and as they'll enthusiastically
assure you none of these people are the
Chinese government case not closed
obviously here's what we
huawei technology LLC is 100% owned by a
holding company called huawei investment
and holding which is itself owned by two
parties who always CEO owns about one
percent and the rest the union of huawei
investment in holding it says this is
only for legal reasons and I'll remind
you
convoluted ownership structures aren't
at all unusual for all practical
purposes Huawei claims the company is
owned by its employees the names in the
blue book who owned stock in the company
but again it's not so simple
what hall we call stock is actually
apologies in advance to non-business
majors synthetic equity or for maximum
put it in the parking lot synergize
circleback jargon points restricted
phantom shares ooh
phantom spooky sounding it's a lot like
regular equity shareholders in this case
Huawei employees receive a share of the
company's profits a dividend they stand
to make money so they're incentivized to
add value to the company except it's
synthetic as in not totally real it
can't be sold or transferred doesn't
give much say in the operations of the
company and if an employee for any
reason leaves the company he or she must
also sell back their shares as two
American researchers summarize quote
this virtual stock ownership has nothing
to do with financing or control it is
purely a profit sharing incentive scheme
when we ask the question who owns Huawei
what we're really asking is who if they
really wanted the company to do
something like say spy on foreign
countries has the power to do so the
answer it seems is the Union who owns
the holding company who owns the company
so who controls the Union this time the
answer is much easier under Chinese
labor law unions are subject to their
superior branch local unions answer to
provincial unions all the way up through
a winding python of hierarchy ending at
the chairman of the old china federation
of trade unions who also sits on the
National People's Congress unions in
China are therefore largely an extension
of the common
party now you'd be right to point out
that this alone shouldn't be enough to
ban an entire company from doing
business with an entire country after
all this logic applies to many Chinese
companies not just Huawei it would be
ridiculous to ban all of them to that
defenders of the ban would say but
hallway is no ordinary company it has a
long history of alleged misbehavior its
CFO was quite prominently arrested in
Canada on the grounds of violating US
sanctions on Iran Cisco accused the
company of copying their manuals after
finding the same typos in hallways which
its CEO said was just a coincidence the
CIA also claims it has evidence that
hallway has taken money from Chinese
intelligence services and finally in
2012 China gave the African Union a new
200 million dollar headquarters in
Ethiopia then last year a French
newspaper quoted anonymous technicians
in the building who claimed they caught
hallway equipment copying and sending
data to servers in Shanghai which China
and the African Union officially deny on
one hand there's a lot of smoke here on
the other there's also a lot of people
who have a strong interest in you
believing there's a fire all of these
incidents are alleged and neither the UK
nor the US has ever presented clear
evidence of a backdoor in Huawei
equipment despite having many years to
investigate before the ban before its
phones were cut off from Google services
before it lost his relationship with arm
before it was indirectly forced to sell
off its undersea cable business hallway
was unstoppable experts tend to agree
that it's years ahead of anyone else on
5g technology and that it's equipment is
in general significantly cheaper that's
why despite pressure from its allies
Britain has continued buying Huawei
equipment doing so saves at least
millions of dollars it mirrors the
predicament many countries around the
world face with Chinese investment even
knowing the risk of dependence on China
can they resist the economic benefits
it's no secret that while this is going
on the u.s. is in a trade war with
and banning Huawei gives it both
negotiating leverage and protects
American telecommunications companies
from foreign competition exactly at its
strongest so make no mistake the ban is
political it's been strongly hinted as
being on the table for trade
negotiations and it's quite possible the
ban will soon be reversed if a deal is
made but it's just as important to note
that just because something is
strategically motivated doesn't mean
there aren't other perfectly legitimate
arguments much of the confusion around
this issue is centered around the fact
that politicians can agree on the same
policy for vastly different reasons the
truth is you don't need to make a
judgment call on whether you trust
Huawei or ATS CEO you only need to
recognise the most basic feature of the
Chinese system everything is the concern
of the state from what is shown on TV to
who is allowed to travel even how long
you can play fortnight and certainly the
movements of its largest corporations
the Communist Party is everywhere if not
now and quite possibly not in the case
of hallway eventually having an enemy is
unfortunately useful for American
politicians especially one as
misunderstood as China but so - is it
crucial for a country to keep its
communications infrastructure through
which national secrets are shared and
information wars increasingly fought
free from foreign influence this is much
bigger than any one company bigger than
who controls 5g bigger even than the
trade war it's really about the Chinese
system being used against it the story
of Huawei is very much the story of
China both only realize their full
potential upon opening up to the world's
markets where hallway now makes much of
its revenue and how China was turned
into one of the most powerful nations on
earth Huawei is what it is today to a
significant degree because of its close
relationship with and subsequent
protection by the Chinese government now
it's a victim of that same closeness the
other side of that very profitable coin
which ironically has long blocked many
Western tech companies Google Facebook
Twitter you too
from operating in China on you guessed
it national security grounds China would
like the benefits of free open trade
abroad while closely protecting and
controlling business domestically but
now it's forced to choose in the trade
war like this one each side is trying to
use game theory to interpret and
outmaneuver their opponent who may or
may not be lying for example say there
are two types of people Knights who
always tell the truth and knaves who
always lie you say if I asked if you
were a knight what would you say and
they respond no which are they night or
knave to see the answer and solve other
problems like this one check out the
interactive logic computer science and
math courses on brilliance you can even
do them offline with their iOS and
Android apps if you want something more
bite-sized brilliant also has daily
challenges in math science and
engineering you can use the link in the
description to start learning for free
and the first 200 people will get 20%
off the annual premium subscription so
you can view all daily challenges and
unlock dozens of problem solving courses
thanks again to brilliant and to you for
watching this video